♪ Le rap, c'est ma thérapie ♪
♪ Microphone check, one-two ♪
W W What is this ♪
- Jocelyn Bruno, alias Dramatik,
je suis très corerererererereres
un pionnier du rap québécois,
entre autres avec le groupe
Muzion. On va y revenir, mais
projet "Royauté".
♪ Pas le choix de suivre ♪
C'est une compilation de
par une trentaine d'artistes
issus des communnonononoires
du Québec. Vous avez amassé
100 000 $ que vous allez1818181r
la persévérance scolaire.
Et pourquoi avoir choisi de
soutenir la persévérance
DRAMATIK, rappeur
- Souv
puis on n'a pas les ressources
ou la tape dans le dos
Et à cette époque-là, à l'âge
de 15 ans, au secondaire, moi,ss
en manque de ressources.
Puis ces jeunes-là, ils ont
besoin d'une passerelle vers
On a un grave problème
d'ilililililité.
Donc, je pense que tout cet
encouragement est béiiiiiiiiiiié
il y a environ 25 ans dans
le quartier Montréal-Nord.
- Vous étiez à l'école Henri-
Bouras a a a a avez déjà dit :
"En tant que bègue, c'est le rap
qui m'a libéré, parce s s s s s"
- Oui.
- Comment le rap vous a aidé?
- Le rap m'a aidé à mettre
je m'enfarge dedans,
parce que sans le rap, comme
vous remarquez, j'ai plusieurs
par la même porte en même temps.
Et puis le rapcocococococomme
mettre une grille. Le rap est
venu m'aider à avoir plusi.i.i..
Le rap a amené... le rap change
le cerveau aussi. Juste le faite
des parties du cerveau.
C'est pas rien, ça!
- Le rap a changé votre vie,
DRAMATIK, rappeur
- Ah o!!!!!!
Je pense que oui. Oui, parce
qu'à cette époque nsnsnsnsnsnsn.
J'étais en appartement à l'âge
de 16-17 ans avec des amis puis
des chums avec des mauvais
venu me mettre sur une grille,pé
à ne pas arrêter. Puis le rap,
ça a
J'ai pu mettre tout mon...
tous mettre mes démons
feuille blanche.
- Vos démons?
- Oui, démons, des cris,
des drames, des traumatismes,
depuis les centres jeunesses.
♪ La panne d'hydro a démontré
notre dépendance au système ♪
décollé en 1996 avec Muzion.
Il y a eu deux
extraordinaires qui ont gagné
d'ailleurs  le Félix de l'anrere
l'expérience Muzion?
- Je retiens l'école.
En fait, c'est une vraie école.
on vient d'une époque où est-ces
qui nous ressemblaient, donc
le
tracé encore. On était
un système d'aeeeeeeee
de sirène, et c'est pas tout
le monde qui veut entendre
Tu sais, tu as des gens qui
veulent mettre des problèmes
en dessous du tapis. Donc je
Les gens qui ont écouté "La vi
ssssssssssssssssi écouté
les autres morceaux comme
"Rien à perdrd"d"d"d"d"d"d"d"d"e
vu que cette musique-là,ssssssss
qui manifestent.u u u u u u u ue
carrière, vous avez manifesté
contre l j j j j j j j j j j j t
à deux chansons :
"L'oubli" et "Révolte vers".
Comment voulez-vous parler
- Et comment ne pas en parler?
On se fait piquer, on souffre,
on se fait brûler. Je veux dire,
part. On regarde les
manifeaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiait qu'on
est encore à l'époque des images
en noir et blanc.
C'est le même message, c'est
les mninininininininininininini,
finalement, de faire c
travail-là juste pour être
accepté. On dirait qu'on doit
d'être là.
Je sais que ça aujourd'hui,
c'est un soir important.
- On vous a vu dans l'excellente
m'efface". On vous a vu à v v vz
trouvé l'expérience?
- Ah, c'était juste géniivivivie
n'aurais jamais osé demander
un rôle parlant, parce que
c'est rare qu'on voit des bègues
de diversité, bien ça en estsssn
de gens qui sont bègues, qui ont
La volonté de partager
mon expérience
que la voix, que la peur qui
m'habite, alors je fonce.spspspr
des jeunes à foncer, parce que
vous faites des ateliers dans
les écoles.
- Qu'avez-vous à direeseseseses?
DRAMATIK, rappeur
- Aux jejejejejejejejejejejejej,
de ne pas arrêter.
Des fois, on en a des idées dans
notre tête qui nous rendent
continuer à nous nourrir cette
flamme-là. Et c'est vous qui
avez raison au final.
entendu.
- Ou
- Dramatik, merci beaucoup.
- Thanks.e e e e e e e e e e e m
sans bégayer ♪
♪ Comme un CD enrayé